I'm a narc I was a narcotics guy forever
but I'm just telling you it's I've
always felt bad for the people that were
addicted to drugs
Gregg sir is a former narcotics officer
and current chief of the San Francisco
Police Department
he's continued in the footsteps of his
predecessor George Cascone by
de-emphasizing drug enforcement and
disbanding the city's Narcotics Unit
while there are many factors that could
account for San Francisco's drop in
violent crime sir believes that San
Francisco's approach has freed up police
resources and made the city a safer
place here in San Francisco after the
recession were down 300 police officers
you can't do everything and the main
thing you want is for people to be safe
I don't have the horsepower anymore to
have a hundred person or Kotik units so
I'm focusing on violent crime we're in a
record low year right now for homicide
so it's working gun violence is down 50%
when George Cascone was chief of police
there were x-men or aprotic arrests and
as of going into last year those those
arrests are off or about 85%
back in the day in the 80s and the 90s
and the 2000s for a good part of it
folks were standing around doing that
folks were controlling entire
neighborhoods that's really not the case
these days to the same degree a lot of
drug sales now happen on the Internet
a lot of drug deliveries happen through
the mail it's just different it's sort
of you know we always laugh you know we
don't have a problem with people
stealing eight-track decks or tape
cassettes anymore because they don't the
automobile industry now pretty much made
breaking the radios out of car or
something that people just don't do
anymore
so a lot of things gone online I'm kind
of a wonk with trying to figure out on
why stuff happens and how I can impact
it and so I'm doubling down on trying to
get violent crime down trying to get
young people jobs not trying to arrest
my way out of it
it's not a high priority to just do the
numbers game because you can make X
amount of arrests it's my position that
you know people that are addicted to
drugs are sick and they need to be
treated as a public health situation and
we do that narcotic enforcement other
than as complaint driven is the odd man
out so we don't clog the courts trying
to prosecute a bunch of drug users we
try to divert them into drug court into
some sort of a program that'll get them
off of narcotics when my community here
in San Francisco asks you know hey how
come under your tenure especially having
been kind of the the street cop the
narcotics cop and the whole thing off
85% I tell them I know what I'm doing
the thing that we're promotive here in
San Francisco is that violent crime is
down I don't know that they're related I
just think that here in San Francisco it
appears we have our priorities straight
not trying to just keep a stat game
going on arresting people for narcotics
has not hurt us in trying to achieve our
goal of making San Francisco safest
we never had no math we don't do math
it's just unbelievable to me that they
would even say that or even think that
this is the LA Sheriff's Department